yeah Tibo told me stories about from the
Xena pulling high balls-out era okay and
seabone said back then the rape in there
was a smell on the run from so many
dudes getting raped Oh
white dudes you know and big guys just
kissing them like they were women
he said that they wouldn't just rape
them with their dicks in their asses
they'd stick like shampoo bottles shanks
they do all kinds of crazy things that
they stick in their asses as well and
yeah I wrote a blog on it called t-bone
on Prison Rape well I can't find it
right now and it gives all the details
to you when I'm able to see it so if
it's on Google leads because there was a
lot of details that I just can't
remember off the top of my head yeah
yeah is he worth Tebow now oh man this
is so sad all right here's an example
then of the injustice against black
people now
t-bone was released from prison he'd
already served like almost four years in
and out in and out 30 okay yeah it must
be any sixties now ever ever since he
got the Marines alright so when you go
out the Marines set himself up as a
bodyguard and he was making up $2,000 a
day now in that lifestyle you know he's
getting on the cocaine mm-hmm he's
getting deep and his crimes we're never
made yet they all revolve around drug
addiction you know like I said he's got
PTSD and stealing for drugs and things
like that so he's a repeat offender
he got out about five or six years ago
and I was on the phone every day with
him trying to get his life story down as
a book because I knew that would give
him credibility to do talks in schools
and churches which is what he wants to
do but I also knew I was in a race
against time with someone like t-bone
gets out of prison the special teams of
cops
watching them they get rewarded somehow
I don't know where they get money I they
get they get cake the career promotions
they got arrest quotas and that kind of
thing they're watching these guys to put
them back in as soon as possible just to
get them off the streets really yeah
that's what it's like that's just like
with these guys and it all went down it
went down there was a SWAT team raid
they put a shotgun to his neighbor's had
some woman asking how did you know to my
dad you know how do you know how did you
know him
she's done nothing wrong so they took
t-bone in and they said a lot you've
done a robbery you're facing a 200 year
sentence if you lose at trial
just sign guilty admit you did the
robbery and you know we'll just bang you
up for 10 or 15 years and he said no
I've not done the robbery now this is
how they break people down if they've
not done the crime they say you're gonna
get a life sentence sign here and people
innocent people will rather risk getting
hundreds of years or dozens of years
they'd rather risk that not risk that
and just sign and get like five years or
ten years rather than because they know
what happens they're not gonna win at
court black guy so t-bone praise and he
believes God has his back and he's not
done it and he says no I'm going to
trial and if a black man's go to trial
in Arizona heaven help you man it's not
gonna happen
trial is just theater whoever's got the
most money puts on the best jean that's
always the state and they give you a
public defender for you know five
thousand pounds budget for a public
defender you can't put on any any kind
of theater show at all so t-bone goes to
trial and his lawyer says to the cop
understand was there a camera at the
location you said he's done this robbery
right yes there was the camera show us
the video of him doing the robbery I
didn't have time to get the video that's
what the cop said they tried it huh
because they know he's more likely to
sign a plea bargain admit guilt for
innocence than go to trial and risk 200
years so he called around on it he won
he was so happy he thought he was
getting out Jory found him innocent so
what did they do they slapped another
charge on him they said he took $20 off
a countertop in the shop found him
guilty and gave him 13 years black lives
do not matter one bit in the US justice
system from what I saw my own experience
and that is one story of many I was
there when a war hero got sent since the
Vietnam vet had been showing the head by
a sniper eight more Purple Heart Medal
for bravery I was known to call
prosecutor said he's unemployed he's got
a nice new car there were some crumbs of
cocaine in it he must be a dealer and
judge was like BAM sent him away for
almost 10 years just like that yeah
these are the people that feed the
system the prison population has to
constantly expand to keep the profits
rolling in Arizona's education budget is
down to what now 20 on the list
something like that in prisons isn't
like the top five I think all about
making money off human suffering and
they go for the most vulnerable people
because if you arrest a rich white kid
that kids family's going to get him a
high-priced lawyer all right kid it's
family might know a prosecutor or a
judge right
to play the odds that go for the poorest
people in society people like Steven
Avery and Brendan Dassey and making a
murderer they're just typical
kind of people that they go after yeah
let's take a quick lateral step back to
when you were in prison and you told a
story about you were working in the
cafeteria or something and you're
cleaning out trays I don't know what you
like had a hole or people just shove
their tray their dirty trays in and you
would like hose them down and you took
like a cigarette break or something you
sat on a crate and someone said get the
[ __ ] off my crate oh so who was that guy
I'm in minimum security and
you know I'm about it's all short-timers
and I think I'm gonna get out soon
nothing no more problems I'm just gonna
go if it's gonna go fine I'm assigned to
the kitchen duty so my job is in what's
called the Clipper room okay now in the
Clipper room that's what you start
remember first day mr. Connell comes up
to me goes this is welcome to Hell's
Kitchen you're gonna be in the Clipper
room it's the hardest job on the art
that's where everybody starts out so I
go in the Clipper room and in the
Clipper room there's like a hole in the
wall where the chow trays come in so in
the chow hall you got 200 prisoners are
marched in out of an oval hole in the
wall comes a tray to them you can't see
the person behind the wall handle you
d'être supposed to stop home we hook ups
you know okay okay yeah so because all
the world trays come out all the wall on
the trays come in 200 people come in
they've got 15 minutes to eat you ain't
finished eating tough [ __ ] you got to
get out so everyone's like in really
fast not chewing properly at the end
about 15 minutes back all the treasures
start coming in one after the other
what answer these change sinks
now you gotta wait you got to get on
these trays and hose them down and move
the next thing and then they all go into
this dishwasher when I when I when I say
dishwasher this thing is like the size
of a drive-in car wash and it was so
broken it had a gas leak and it was
every now and then it was shoot out
flames and people's hurt people's oh yes
oh my god there were days when we
revolted because it was like making
these noises like it was going to
explode yeah it was mental the guy
running the kitchen was a white shirt
when I say run in the kitchen it's an
outside employee
prisoner was a white shirt was this
African Chi we call blood diamonds and
what we say like you know it's gonna
blow it's gonna blow up
we're stopping working it's like there's
nothing you can do keep working keep
working you always you know just pushing
us pushing this pushing us
[Music]
[Laughter]